welcome to the party
i am making my own creations
to help me capture the slurs hello
deeply disappointing experiments
gargamel is a celebrity this time around
we like reached a real a real level of
fame which i'm sure has changed them to
some degree
celebrities always have that list of
what they must have in their dressing
room what do you think is maybe right at
the top maybe that top three list
i can tell you right away he insisted on
portraits of himself okay done by
varied artists
anything else other than the photos
rocks okay very good very good and cat
toys of course okay right talk to me
about paris what's the takeaway paris
was unbelievable when do you get to go
to normally you're spending thousands of
dollars to stay in a hotel and
and and plan your own itinerary we're
flown to paris we get put up in a hotel
and we get per diem the downside is that
i was there by myself uh and then the
most romantic city in the world and
didn't speak the language of course i
was created in france so i have a
certain je ne sais quoi yes you do vexi
i thought the paris fashions were
smurftastic
i get so puffy when i travel i get puffy
too it's it's the uh air pressure that
changes in the airplanes and it gives
you a little that under chin i know
exactly what you mean victor you look
fouled
oh yes i did oh yes i did when you when
you talk to actors who get into these
characters that are completely
transformations this whole other kind of
personality sometimes there's a point of
reference of maybe a real person is
there anyone that you're channeling here
secretly no
i occasionally
uh
you know my mother comes to mind she was
wrangling us
when we were being really unruly and she
was at her wit's end such a frightening
mother
she was never as scary as gardening
about that goodness the attention you're
getting now your superstars everywhere
you go you've got paparazzi being the
only girl in smurf village i'm kind of
used to it no pictures please well
my brother hackus and i cause a
commotion everywhere we go hack us to
the rescue
don't you agree that smurfs should
possibly go to broadway
and maybe
la la la la la could become like a real
number
i like that idea
and i thought i had a bad sign
in the smurf berries
the smurfs too
how dare you
[ __ ]